the gyro can experience this visit seem
real hey still yeah of course is real up
for the first few weeks the first few
days I was pinching myself see if those
throws a dream are nothing but you know
I'm just really blessed to be here I'm a
durable situation right you got so like
how many weeks out did you find out
about the fight I think I was like a
month a month in two weeks
Wow month in two weeks I message ad
Hearns I tell him you know what give me
the opportunity and what do you know
your message back me and my girl were
just all happy like well it was crazy
Wow and you were already in camp right
mm-hmm
so like wasn't like heat they called you
out of shape no elbows after my fight
against Alexander dammit Renko oh that's
right how much time did you have off to
recover
I just took like a week and a half off
oh that's night I went back to the gym
and I was just ready and loose so it was
it couldn't happen in a perfect time
that's amazing do you like it like that
where you just experienced a big fight
so you're already kind of used to the
the being in the ring being on
television the whole moment of it all
and that boom it happens again right
afterwards yeah of course you know
because I was already loose I was
already in fight mode so especially from
having the heavyweight champion title
you know the opportunity to get that
it's it was amazing it was incredible
fight man was in crowd thank you it was
really amazing was amazing was when you
got dropped you kept your composure you
got up and then he tried to move in for
the kill and then you started landing
bombs on him and dropped him and I
remember jumping off the bed while I was
watching oh [ __ ] it was wild man yeah
fight it was my first time getting
dropped and you know what
I don't feel super hurt you know because
I had when I got drop he hit me with a
good right hand and I took like a champ
but I got a man and I just throwing
bombs you have fluid punches man I mean
it's it's really interesting to watch
you're so efficient like the way you
throw punches
you're not like grunting and [ __ ]
digging like there's a lot of guys that
you see there's
a tremendous amount of energy that's
expended every time they throw punches
but you man your punches just come in
bunches its pop you just moments the
combinations I would be working at the
gym
many robliz that's why I had a trainer
who throws a lot of combinations as good
at working speed so I think we click
really good together well it's such a
big asset for heavyweights because most
heavyweights they're throwing big bombs
and they're looking for that one punch
yep
yeah and you you just pile them on man
and you're throwing them on all these
angles and especially when you get in
tight with dudes you know like when
you're in tight with dudes in these
dogfights your punches are coming at all
these different angles and so fluid it's
beautiful to watch man Thank You Man
especially with these big guys I love
fighting bigger guys you know some one
time I fought a guy that was shorter
than me and it was kind of hard so
imagine me pressuring bigger guys and
throwing these combinations it works for
me really good it does and you're the
first-ever Mexican heavyweight champion
of the world man thanks to God it's
crazy man I mean you are in the same
league as Cain Velasquez the first-ever
UFC Heavyweight Champion that was
Mexican yeah I mean that's that's just
incredible honor man mm-hmm
thanks man I've lighter shirt that the
love you must be getting from all the
metas oh my gosh I can't even go to the
store without taking so many pictures
people are on lines they get off like
say if I'm gonna drive through somewhere
they get off of their car and tries to
take pictures but it's a blessing you
know I really appreciate all my fans all
the supporters it's amazing man and you
know what was really cool was the
post-fight press conference when you're
talking about it were you like damn you
know we made it and you know we're
saying we're saying my mom yeah your mom
that was beautiful yeah I mean because a
lot of people don't know that we're
we're struggling a lot even before this
fight you know and going through a lot
of the stuff with top ranked with Bob
Aaron of me not getting a lot of fights
waiting waiting because I had one more
fight left with them so they didn't want
to let me go so I had to pay my
pay it off so thank you now yeah
everything's turned around so quick
sorry Bob
[ __ ] up yeah well there's a lot of
dudes who were not interested in finding
you you know I see it was one of those
things where you were incredibly
talented and incredibly skilled but you
didn't have the base name yet so there
wasn't like a lot of money in it yet but
there was a giant risk and a lot of the
insiders were very very aware of this
you know guys who really follow boxing
were very aware of this and coming into
that fight like I talked to a lot of
people that are like big boxing fans and
they're like that dude is a live dog
that's a live dog like it mean for sure
Anthony Joshua was a bad [ __ ]
he's a big giant muscular dude looks
like Adonis but they were like any
Ruiz's a live dog he could win that
[ __ ] because because when they see me
they're like look at this chubby kid
Manny he's gonna get tired really fast
he's he's gonna get knocked out but the
real people that know about boxing they
they know the skills that I have the
movement yeah I could get a little bit
more fit and more leaner you know get
the like the extra fat turning into
muscle I'll love to do that you know but
the thing is people love you because
you're kind of chubby yeah because I
mean well it's also you you like you
like hey you know people that go to the
beach and want to take their shirt off
you're like [ __ ] man Andy Ruiz is kind
of built like me yeah and he's the champ
of the world yeah give give this big guy
is confident it makes a big deal like
you remember when Butterbean well pata
bean was obviously never a champ but you
know people a lot of beans because he
was this big fat guy I would [ __ ] people
up you know what I took a picture with
butter bean when I was like then I was
like five years old six years old in
Tijuana he fought over there and he was
a big guy man big guy he was a tank man
that dude had some [ __ ] power starch
people you know he really couldn't go
past four or five rounds but he would
put a [ __ ] beating on you for four
rounds never seen when Johnny Knoxville
from that that crazy [ __ ] decided hey
I'm bleeding but he thinks he let him
punch him for some crazy reason he
decided to try to box with
Butterbean just brained him it was this
it's not good
mmm don't do that to people that know
I'm gonna sign a waiver for